back again are we
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to people's playground
this has been a highly requested video
of mine i don't know why i'm talking so
softly and you're going to have to crank
up your volume because i'm going to only
talk like this now
this is a bad bit and i'm not going to
keep doing it so i want to give you a
chance to turn down your volume because
i'm going to start talking louder now
and while we're good hey
there's been some updates some updates
to this but i want to go to the abyss
just because i want to see it again
right
[Music]
um
i swear there used to be lights
in here
oh someone hit pause
there we go hi
oops uh oh
okay okay okay okay
well that's terrifying what does this do
wire
power propagate oh
hmm
i forgot i forgot about this
bam
damn
oh
that seems even better than last time
unless it was just that cool before
which maybe it was holy sh
snookies
or anyway
no
yeah there we go
let's get you out here all right let's
put a row boat
why didn't why is it why does it have
health there we go
just keep going man that was a lot of
damage to the crotch
all right see you buddy and
there we go
okay now how does a human fare
[Music]
i forgot they feel pain i forgot about
the pain
let's get you out of here right and then
this dude
oh yeah oh yeah oh i forgot about that
you all right he's not great
but this guy's okay if i recall
correctly
all right you work on that for a while
okay now that we're back to where we
should be which is a perfectly good
place that makes perfectly logical sense
we're gonna explore some of the things
that
anyway we're gonna get back to some of
the things that made this game amazing
oh
he don't like the old none of them like
that oh you're on fire oh
well i'll get that out of there
all right buddy
oh that don't look good
yeah pelvis into the floor usually
spells doom
um oh there's new vehicles
there's new bomb spike grenade signal
flare red barrel pink explosives land
mines sticky grenade general purpose
bomb fireworks energy vessel explosive
emp
i'm guessing that was something falling
into the pit dynamite fusion bomb and
adam
well let's see
what happens
when we drop a fusion bomb can't pause
can we
follow here we go we're dropping a
fusion bomb into the pit now i don't
know if it's going to detonate at the
bottom
that pit's much bigger than i remember
and the doom that lies at the bottom is
a little more mystical than i think you
ignite
i don't like it
i don't like it down here guys
i don't like it down here
blowing up blowing up blowing up
oh even they got launched
[Music]
[Laughter]
well that was pretty cool and then what
happens when you want
oh
yeah
[Music]
isn't there like a heel juice
mending heals nearly anything if i
recall
i got a wait
okay there was a way to actually use it
right it wasn't just willy-nilly there
was something about it okay there was a
way to stop it from rotating i should
look up the controls no
rotate yes yes
there we go
jam okay and wham okay and
okay
live damn it
live all right fine he doesn't want to
live a
flask full of course blood
oil live damn it live eat your oil
oil
eat your oil eat your oil eat your oil
eat your oil your oil oil oil oil oil
oil oil oil come on oil oil oil oil oil
oil okay i know how to do this i know
the perfect solution what we're gonna do
is we're going to
make the oil go into his body no matter
what let's just put this right
this is brilliant on the end i'm a
genius
damn this is a tough flask all right
well your legs can provide a convenient
entry point for the oil i won't give up
on you man i don't even know your name
whoa
hang on
hey wait oh okay i won't give up on you
man
i don't even know your name but hold on
all right ass in place make the delicate
connection here
yes
there we go
all right so the oil uh doesn't seem to
want to go in
it's got to be something to do with this
oil right
it's got to be right there's no other
way that i can think a robot needs its
oil
so the only logical step
is to take the next logical step
am i right people i am right
[Music]
hey there he is hey where'd your ass go
okay you feeling better are you feeling
peppy okay well he's uh looking spicy
but his ass must have gotten blasted to
the oh there's his ass
and the oil what is that supposed to be
whoa
lore
oh my god lore oh my god it's lore link
lick lynxian
hey god you are not lixian who the
are you
i'm gonna need you to leave
thank you
thank you lore lixian ring the lore
alarm
now i have to look this up
six two eight three one eight
okay
six two eight
three one eight five three zero
five three zero seven one seven
six two eight three one eight five three
zero seven one seven oh wait maybe there
was one more letter one more number
nine
nine five nine five
modulo two dot jpeg
i'm guessing
i forgot you were there buddy oh it's
just your ass okay yeah i'll go hang on
one second i gotta deliver an ass
okay and
where'd your legs go ass is all you need
to thunk i hope that's the right end of
your ass
uh-huh
okay anyway medullo 2 i'm guessing it
probably put the game in the steam
folder here medullo 2.
it looks like we don't support this file
format interesting
okay so it's not actually a jpeg i've
run into these before
it's actually
a
archive folder i i didn't actually look
that up that's just my guess i might be
wrong about it okay what i probably
gotta do is rename it
let's try
let's make it a rar file
okay let's make it a zip file
let's try zip
but it's definitely not a jpeg
that's for sure
so if it's not a jpeg
there's probably people that have
already solved this and i'm probably
wasting my time
medullo2.jpg again quite scary
okay
in a browser called yandex
whoa what the
what the okay so once you do that
all right i gotta leave big gut
okay
i'm going to tiny
wait that is tiny okay never mind maybe
not tiny
there's something about this game
that
isn't what it seems there's something
going on here
okay this is just a big old penis tower
great not what i'm looking for
where's the hybrid
oh god
oh oh
whoa what the frick
gavar
zeke lev harm
hey how you doing
how about an android
give a thumbs up give it that thumbs up
thumbs up on the way down
and down you go
there he is
oh
no
oh no
oh i hate that i hate that let's make it
worse
be free wow this is so much bigger than
i thought it was okay be free
you guys alive can you swim
can these things swim
they seem to be all right is this really
all that wait
is this this isn't all of the
things wait a minute there were way more
what is going on
the wrench i forgot about the wrench i
forgot about the wrench ah that's right
the whole situation is that i need to
download many many mods because
otherwise it's just going to get sad
well i'm going to try something before i
do anything else
why did it get red
why is it very red
why does it get redder the more ids i
put what is that about
why is this it's so red
here we go
what is that about
what is that
what is that about what's down there
what is this
what is this what is this
i can't say anything what but i saw
something down here
what was that why was there
was there just a room down in the
nothingness somewhere down here there
was a room
why
i don't really know
there
why
why are you here
what is this
it's a room with lots of piping
why
why is this down here and why can you
only see it when you blow something up
there's weirdness in this game
and i don't like it
i don't like it i don't like the secrets
i don't like them i feel like i'm being
watched when i play this game so
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go out of
the game and i'm gonna look at the mods
and i'm just gonna see if there's
anything else
[Music]
okay lore aside the game is still about
blowing things up i'm going back to the
hybrid
because
it seems to hold some mystery and also
some potential hey
look it's people
hello
oh
what do you think of this guy
all right how about this guy
no right how about her
all right okay all right okay all right
excuse me
easy there
okay interesting
so a canister of human suffering i don't
know what that's going to do
also apparently the wind is blowing this
way
something's happening hey a tank cool
oh
uh buddy oh boy
that's not gonna be good let's forget
about you for a second let's drop an
unsuspecting
uh
someone into
wow that's a lot of people
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
make a dude we got a dude right and then
we're gonna make a syringe
it's going to make him breathe
underwater
give me that give me that
give give give give
give give
give give it give it give it give thank
you and
there we go
stab
and he's good okay he's good great great
this is great this is exactly what i was
hoping for
all right so you good buddy all right
you stay good because uh i'm gonna need
you to
really be strong
because i want you to survive this
journey
oh yeah
oh yeah okay very strong
very strong
so you probably are invincible right
something like that
okay mr invincible man
you are going to uh
accompany this
ah let's make it an anchor let's make it
thematic tie your ankle to that all
right you're good and then i'm just
gonna follow you follow and we're just
gonna take nope undo that uh let's get
back to our pointer and just gonna take
this and drop that down
all right you have a good journey
this has been uh my return to people's
playgrounds there's still a lot more to
this game that i have not explored
in addition to all of the lore it seems
that there's a lot of things
in terms of mod ability in the game and
just general enjoyability about possibly
building some horrible contraptions that
murder uh the unsuspecting inhabitants
of your
of your uh
world and also their secrets and
horrible secrets at that links in the
description if you want to play it is
available let me see if i can make him
make his journey a little bit faster
here i don't know if this is going to
help with the sinking
just in case he gets any bright ideas
about ever coming back to the surface so
yeah this has been the adventure of this
dude and uh the things that he's going
to deal with when he's down into the in
the depths of uh despair
which he's rapidly approaching
kind of sinks a little
faster there we go now we're talking now
he gets to see where he's going
which is even better
just gonna help speed him along a little
bit
[Music]
where'd he go
oh no what am i looking at undo undo
okay so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the first episode of
this that i did in the link in the
description below and
as always have a lovely day
see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
you